this
is the image with which we did the next
caption
contest that's sassy the cat and i
laying on the bed she likes to pop up
there that's her favorite spot she likes
to be right at the edge of the bed
and basically curled up in my arms and
chest she uses my hand as a pillow
during the night and this is in the
morning uh
i think she had been staying up there
and i was i was just coming up there to
hang out with her and
took a picture she looks a little bit
unhappy about being photographed she
doesn't actually like to be
on camera she seems to realize there's
something when the the phone goes in
front of her face
and so i asked people to provide
some captions i'm going to give you the
the top 10
in just a moment but before that let's
look at some
puns aggregated here so
we've got you know he still hasn't
finished the phenomenology of
meow it's a categorical imperative that
sassy can sit on the couch this is
actually
the bed of course chilling with my guy
after talking about albert
cut moose okay uh another one the cat
sublated my homework there's a hegel
joke there right and also the reference
to the
the dog ate my homework joke that gets
made quite a bit
finally a longer one sacrifices
sansephus contemplates her eternal
struggle to bring dr sadler a mouse
only to have him throw it away at the
last minute according to the myth of
sasyphus
this represents the absurdity of all
feline existence even though we must
imagine her
happiness a very long reference to
albert camus
myth of sisyphus playing off of sassy's
name
so those are you know some decent jokes
here are the
top ten this is a good one
and you gotta know a little bit about
american culture in order to to get this
rare footage of local home depot
employee refusing to help customer
whilst on the job home depot uses orange
as one of their colors it's a big
store like lowe's or some others
where you go in and you buy your your
home things
lumber furnishings all the things you
need to do
work on your own and so you know this
this makes sense within that context
here's another good one pov point of
view
you're the abyss and you are staring
back at them
i'm not quite sure who the abyss is
supposed to be in this case me
sassy both of us combined the camera on
the phone itself
which could work but it's it's kind of a
good joke right there
here's another pretty funny one just
found schrodinger's cat turns out he was
just
in time out this is kind of a funny one
too because
not only would schrodinger's cat could
be alive could be dead
right and apparently can also be a he or
a she
in this case as well because sassy is a
girl cat
schrodinger's cat is is you know part of
that
thought experiment where we don't know
until we open the box whether the cat
is alive or dead and here we're saying
it's a third state of being in time
out now we get to some things that are a
bit more directly philosophical
so good morning class to start today's
zoom meeting we have a guest here to
demonstrate an ethical dilemma for us to
explore
going by utilitarian ethics is it moral
to pet sassy the cat even though it will
bring down our collective
collective productivity let's discuss
and this is kind of a good one because
i'll tell you you know in the last
year and a half well really about a year
of doing everything online although i
was teaching online for
close to a decade before the pivot to
online
um sassy would often come on camera you
know she would want some attention and
hop up in my lap or
you know and students love that sort of
thing as a matter of fact
oftentimes students will have their dogs
or cats or other pets
on camera and other students will look
at that now the question is does this
bring down
our collective productivity or does the
pleasure
remember utilitarianism is about
pleasure does that conduce
to providing nice little breaks that
make us more productive and i i would
actually argue it's the
the second here's another good one
sassy's reaction when she finds out what
descartes and thought thought about the
mental and moral capacities of animals
and it's it's interesting because
there's some self-referentiality here
in order for sassy to find out
what say a philosopher like descartes
who thought that animals are basically
just meat machines
what they thought about animals she
would have to be capable of thought
in a way that would go against what
descartes himself
is saying and you know if an animal
did discover what descartes or thought
or
kant or others who consider animals
basically
not to have minds in the sense that we
do
not have conscious thoughts and not to
be capable of
the kind of thinking that that we are
i think if they found that out they
probably would be kind of miffed and
that would be itself
a reaction that shows that there is more
to their thinking than we
credit them with now we get to some
hegel stuff
uh besides the sub late my homework
welcome to little sassy's lecture on the
hegelian dialectic i
i is mistress you is slave ready your
notepads human
yeah the master slave dialectic i think
is the go-to for most people who want to
talk about hegel
we have a few more here as well although
this one
isn't directly referring to hegel it's a
bit broader today class we go over the
most important question in cat
philosophy
in relation to the cat and human dynamic
who owns
who and it's quite true with cats right
there's the old joke that dogs have
masters
and cats have staff or there's other
variations on that and then here we get
one that refers to
nietzsche i think more than hegel is
this kibble really worth living in slave
morality
look and now
is a cat living in slave morality by
accepting that i don't think so because
cats don't do an
awful lot of enforced activities
compared to dogs uh now we we move on to
like huh
and here's uh kind of an interesting one
the others
juice at work and that may be rather
mysterious to you
why is other in capital o because for
lacan who's writing in french it's the
large a right and then jewish sons what
is that
well it means a lot of different things
over the course of lacan's career
but it all it signifies we could call it
a pleasure beyond the pleasure principle
or
an enjoyment of something
and this is actually i kind of like this
one because this raises
a lot of interesting questions you know
when
when you're petting a cat is it just
about enjoyment
you know it's the pleasure principle
that's why the cat will try to get you
to
keep on petting it over and over again
until perhaps it you know get sick of
that or bites you
actually sassy never does that sassy
just wants more and more pets
um and you know the human being can
enjoy it too
actually anselm of canterbury has a
really interesting example of
the accumulation of pleasures he's
talking back in monastic times
and he talks about um the pleasure of
petting a white cat of caressing a white
cat you know
we would say stroking it and all that
and interestingly he doesn't use
the latin word katus he uses the word
musa keps which means
mouse catcher showing that it's it's got
a function
right but then you go beyond its its
function so that's probably enough about
jhui sauce at this point
uh and then here's one that's uh
adapting the symposium
aristophanes famous idea
about soul mates when a person meets the
half that is his very own whatever his
orientation whether it's to cats or not
then something wonderful happened the
two are struck from their senses by love
a sense of belonging to one another
and by desire and they don't want to be
separated from one another not even
for a moment so adapting the
you know idea of having your missing
half right so
very nice romantic notion um
in terms of the cat human relationship
and
really quite when it when it comes down
to it i am sassy's human
she and i made friends very very early
on
and clicked and
she she does go looking for me when she
can't find me
sometimes i'm gone from the apartment
sometimes i'm just
on the top floor when she's on the
bottom floor or vice versa
and she does not like that at all
all right so if you want to get in on
the next caption
contest if this is something that you
think is cool and you'd like to
get involved in it you'll want to watch
for
my community tab on your youtube channel
if you've got your notifications turned
off
for my channel you probably want to turn
them on so that you
are aware when i post the next picture i
do about
one or two a month and yeah you can
certainly get in on the next one
if you'd like to see your caption
featured
here in one of these videos thanks
everybody who contributed
and that's it for this one
you